Joe Rogan is a six-time MMA personality
of the Year winner and has been featured
in three EA Sports video games
he went from growing up with an abusive
father and being terrified of being
called a loser as a child to having one
of the most popular podcasts and YouTube
channels on the planet and today we're
going to learn his best advice to how to
keep your ego in check rise and shine
it's an espresso time hey it's Evan
Carmichael and every morning I bring you
a shot of espresso to help you believe
in yourself more and start your day with
confidence so good morning I believe in
you let's do this Joe Rogan tell us how
we can put our ego in check I was
talking to a friend of mine about
imposter syndrome that imposter syndrome
yeah you know that feeling you don't
expression no it's you get it when like
when people think that you're really
good at something and you don't have a
lot of self-worth or you you you have
this perception of yourself that you're
not worthy right you know it may be as
an artist that's it's a big one that you
have it as an artist like I had it
forever as a comedian and I probably
still have it a little bit but less so
than I used to because I'm just more
accomplished and more understanding of
what it is and the more engrossed in the
process and I I know what it is now more
than I did before okay and you like what
I meet famous people if they know who I
am i plug oh my god knows who I am I'm
tricking them right trick they don't
know and they're like hey man I love
your stuff I'm like no you don't you
think you know you don't trust me let me
get away from you right it's like this
imposter thing and then sometimes things
enough things happen where you go you
know what I think I might be legit
I think I might be legit like this is so
crazy like I thought I was an impostor
forever but I think I'm gonna relax and
just concentrate on the work and not
worry about whether or not a minute
stur anymore and just concentrate on the
work that ego is always there yeah
that's always there man and but the the
ego it's interesting imposter syndrome
is often more prevalent in people or
legitimately talented and for some
strange reason because when you're
legitimately talented one of the ways
you become legitimately talented is to
be ruthlessly self-critical because
that's that's how you get really good at
something and in ruthless self like I
remember um Katt Williams was talking
about himself once and Katt Williams
who's a crazy person but a brilliant
comedian and he said something that I
have always thought and he's like I'm
not a fan of me and he goes it goes like
I don't you know I don't particularly
like me you know it's like that is why
he's great because that makes you work
so hard at like the worst thing a
comedian can be in the beginning is sure
of themselves and then incompetent at
the same time it's horrible
that's horrible because you're not good
but you think you're amazing and then
you understand you don't know why the
world doesn't think you're amazing
because you think you're great because
you're delusional you have this sort of
artificial image of the world that
you've put up in in the world you are
the center you're the center and you
want everything to evolve around you
impostor syndrome exists because your
your ego won't like your mind
understands that you ego will [ __ ] this
up
if you if you let your ego say oh I'm
good man you're gonna ruin this whole
thing you have to you have to be aware
of what this is like this this this ride
requires you to stay within a certain
frequency you have to stay inside that
frequency as soon as you start going
yeah everything's awesome but it all
goes away all that goes away you have to
stay inside that frequency and that
frequency is not a frequency where
you're very pleased with yourself you
have to be your biggest critic as well
as your biggest cheerleader most of us
will be our own worst critics but not
our own biggest cheerleaders some of us
will be our own biggest
your leaders but not self criticized
enough you need to be both critic and
cheerleader and have the self-awareness
to know which one you need right now
most in the moment so Monday is my
mentoring day and this past Monday I was
mentoring Alex who's on my team he helps
me run Tirana dance salsa and I recently
gave him an exercise that I call the
pillow test where every night before you
go to bed you're scoring yourself out of
ten for how you felt the effort was for
the day not the results that you got but
the effort and he created his score
sheet out of ten what leads to attend
for him and one of the things he was
doing was if you got a 9 out of 10
feeling like oh I got 90 percent it's a
pretty good day and I was telling him no
that's not enough that 9 out of 10 does
not equate to 90 percent on a test you
should be hitting 10 out of 10 every
time unless you're proud of the reason
why you didn't hit it when when I broke
my neck and it was on my tour and I
still when I did Instagram live sessions
I committed I was gonna do an Instagram
live every day and I was doing half an
hour to an hour every day
my first Instagram live in the hospital
was for like 4 minutes 5 minutes and I
you know I started getting lazy eyed and
post it wasn't the best result but I
still did it
I still showed up I'm still proud of my
effort and so he said well how do I know
the difference how do I know if that now
I'm gonna attend is something that is
amazing or or something really bad at
the end of the day you have to look at
that list you have to look at what you
did for the day and ask yourself are you
proud of the effort that you put in I
think we're way too easy on ourselves I
think too often we're just too easy on
ourselves we're not a harsh enough
critic on ourselves that you know you're
capable of doing more and so for me I'll
default to 95% of the time I'm my critic
it's based off of a pillar of love right
at the foundation of self-love when when
you love yourself you can be way harder
on yourself way harder on yourself than
other people are I think we should be
hard on ourselves 95% of the time and
then 5% of the time you have to be
actually more gentle on yourself
5% of the time you got to figure out you
know what I did a good job I'm proud of
what I did today when you're feeling
really low and in the hole and
borderline depressed getting hard on
yourself isn't gonna work right it just
further creates depression so that's we
need to be gentle on yourself you need
to pat yourself on the back more and say
you're doing the best that you can
sometimes it means just getting out of
bed is doing the best that you can again
when I broke my neck just getting into
bed was the best that I could on some
days but more often than not you can go
harder you can do more you need to be
your own biggest critic more so that's
the balance it's being both your biggest
cheerleader and your biggest critic and
having the self-awareness to know which
one you need more right now in the
moment to help you move forward so how
do you do it I've got a three step
process that I think will help but
before that if you want to learn how to
have more self-love I have a 254 series
for you where every day for the next 254
days I'll send you an email for free
with a link to a video that will help
you build yourself love the link to join
is in the description below it's good to
treat other people the way you would
like to be treated yourself it's like a
golden rule and there's a reason for and
that reason is that we're connected okay
here's my three-step process on how you
can be your biggest critic biggest
cheerleader and know the difference
between them so step number one is a
pillow test and the pillow test is
asking yourself before you hit your head
on the pillow at night so tonight before
I'm gonna go to bed I'm gonna ask myself
am i part of my effort and this is a
great check-in every single day because
you may not have gotten the results what
what the world is judging you by in
terms of how many followers you have or
revenue coming in or dollars in your
bank account or all the things all the
results that you're being judged by by
yourself by your peers by your friends
by your family by the people in your
industry it's easy to get lost in those
are you proud of your effort ask
yourself every night are you proud of
the effort that you put in today yes or
no or if you want to do it like Alex a
scale out of 10 number 2 ask yourself do
I need to be harsher on myself or more
gentle on myself is today the day I need
to beat myself up and say I need to do a
better job or say that I need to be a
little more gentle myself and say it's
okay I fell off the wagon I'm gonna get
back on and do it which one do you need
learning to ask yourself those two
questions
of my effort and do I need to be more
gentle or harsher on myself and learning
the difference and applying it on a
daily basis will change your life and
then set number three is what will you
do differently tomorrow so it's a it's a
daily check-in it's a daily check-in the
figure out are you proud of yourself
do you need to be harsher or more gentle
on yourself and then what's gonna change
tomorrow how will I show up differently
tomorrow
how will I apply more of my max effort
tomorrow and if you did that process
every single even tonight you'll notice
it on a 1-up it you'll notice you ask
yourself that question tonight tomorrow
will be better tomorrow be may be
massively better but at least slightly
better and if you do that consistently
if every day you ask yourself those
three questions and then the next day
was slightly better you're gonna start
compounding you're gonna start making
every day much much much much much
better that then again you look back
three six twelve months your life is
completely different
most people never check in most people
are just their biggest critic and they
don't love themselves enough they're not
the biggest cheerleader most people
never think about how can tomorrow
actually go better most people never
think to reward the effort most people
never think to reward themselves and tie
their self-worth and and how proud they
are of the effort that they're putting
in that's what most people I'm happy
that's why most people aren't chasing
their dreams that's what most people
aren't getting the result that they want
in their life
follow that three-step process and your
life will change take the pillow test
rank yourself for how proud you are of
your effort ask yourself you need to be
more harsh to more gentle on yourself
and then ask yourself what will be
different tomorrow three steps to change
your life now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question the day I
want to know so far up to today you
still have time before you go to bed
unless you're watching this in bed but
so far up to today out of 10 how would
you rank your effort and we do you want
to be by the end of the day and what you
need to do to get to a 10 let me know
put it down the comments below and if
you're still here watching you made a
dis four in a video and you promise to
take action after watching it we don't
just watch videos we do something in our
life about them give me a hashtag
believe down the comments below I want
to celebrate you loyalty
and not forgetting what you thought and
where you were and when you started you
know it's so important in business yeah
gosh man I just because when the money
first of all when you're losing money
yeah everybody wants to point the finger
at whose fault it is
and then when it turns around and start
making money everybody wants to say it's
me me me and then you start having
differences in opinions and and you see
all these great things break up because
of ego yeah um or money like you telling
me Guns and Roses can't get together and
go on a tour and play how long one of my
favorite bands ever the Eagles how long
the Eagles went without playing together
you know because come on you guys I mean
it's just ego and and and that type of
stuff ruins some of the greatest
products some of the greatest businesses
some of the greatest friendships bands
and it's just completely unnecessary if
you want more in spread some morning
videos they're not on this channel
anymore I have a dedicated channel just
for it it's right there next to me go
click it there continue to believe and
I'll see you there